(audience cheering and clapping)
- The Voice has been on for 17 seasons,
so my first question obviously had to go
to the two that have been
here since the beginning.
I mean, from the first season,
what do you think has changed the most?
- Well, Blake's hair is much grayer.
(Kelly laughs)
That's just for starters,
off the top of my head.
- And I've added this third chin.
- I found one of those too!
(all laughing)
- You know, we never thought this show,
people thought we were
crazy, and I say "we"
because I think I was the
first hire on the show
when NBC came to us
and myself and Adam Levine both,
were not huge Idol
watchers, I was in radio,
I worked at KROQ here in
Los Angeles, I was at MTV.
- Yeah.
- And these shows on TV
where people were singing,
at the time, don't have the
credibility that they have now.
- No.
- So getting The Voice, when
we watched the tape of it,
it was happening in another country
and it was beating Idol and
X-Factor and all these shows.
We really liked the idea
of coaches helping people
and not just coaches,
but the best in the best in the business.
So just from the conception of the show,
the idea was warm and it
seemed like mentoring, helping.
And those are the themes that I think
has helped the show last for 17 seasons.
In Idol, if one of your judges left,
it was like, "Oh, there's
trouble in paradise!"
You know, "Simon's leaving!"
It was like drama, but
for us, it was like,
well, of course Shakira's
gonna go, she's got a tour.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I think our rotating chairs
has helped the show last long too.
- And yeah, it's always fun
to see different artists.
- [Carson] Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
- We've had some great ones too.
- Yeah, what's different
for you, coaching wise?
'Cause you, I'm gonna brag on you,
and I do this all the time when I say
you really do help people afterward.
And from that first season
you have been so helpful
to all the artists afterwards,
and it's a lot of time.
- Well, I think you gotta
draw the line somewhere,
at some point, you know?
And I think what I've found
for me over the years,
there's just some people that you have
a stronger connection
with, obviously, in life,
and I meet so many people,
I was talking backstage a while ago,
I think I've worked with over
200 artists now on the show.
- Oh my gosh, that's crazy!
- And they all live with
him, which is weird!
- Yeah.
- That's the line that I'm talking about.
I literally.
- Line in the sand.
- They can't shower with you but.
- He literally does though.
He has it like a youth hostel in Oklahoma
where all the past contestants
all live in his back house.
He's too kind.
- It started to feel that way for a while.
After the first season I was a coach,
I think I probably lost money.
- You probably did.
- You try to do stuff for people.
- You were like paying
for apartments for a year
and it was crazy.
- Wow, join Team Blake.
(all laughing)
I am not willing to offer
all the perks that he is.
- The cool thing about the show is
you get to work with
people outside of genres
that you really sing
in and you perform in.
And that's what I love about it.
What has it taught you?
Like Blake you're in country music,
but you've been working
with people in soulful pop,
like all different kinds of genres.
What has that kind of taught you
about different genres of music?
- Speaking of the first
season, I remember thinking,
cause I had, remember Dia Frampton was on
and she was wanting to do all that.
I was thinking like,
oh she's wanting to do
some pop stuff, you know?
I'll get some Billy Ocean.
- Right.
- Something like that, you know.
That's what in my mind,
oh, some Cindy Lauper,
that's what we're gonna
and then she's wanting
to do all these people
like Kanye West, what?
Like, what are you talking?
Who's that, when is that?
When did that come out, you know?
And so, first season was just a huge
learning curve for me, you know?
And it changed.
- Well you won with Jermaine,
was it second season?
- Yeah, I think it was, it
changes also the records
that you make as an artist, you know,
cause you start becoming
exposed to all this other stuff.
That's why I rap now.
(all laughing)
- Exactly.
- Learning who Kanye was, yeah.
I do think it has some effect though.
- [Gwen] For sure.
- Yeah, what about you
like working with honors?
You never thought you.
- This is the thing, going
off of what you said about the
time period of where, when
my band came out and what we,
how we like just evolved in the
TV shows and all that stuff.
I think that I just didn't even
know anything about the show
when I joined it,
but it has been one of the
most inspirational things that
I've ever done in my entire career.
And I've already been alive a long time.
So it's been like a major, I mean,
because it's not only are
you playing a different role,
you know, like it's this kind
of coaching motherly role.
It's also like you're exposed
to all this different music.
You're hearing it in like
through different voices
and you're like looking
up music all the time.
So you're seeing and
hearing music so much.
So it's really, it's very, very like,
it affects you as an artist.
- Yeah.
- And then you get to sit
next to John legend and,
and he's like.
It's crazy.
- Sexy.
- Sexiness man alive.
- I think we're aware.
- I'm between so much
sexiness, look at me.
Oh.
(all laughing)
I don't know what to do.
- So what about, okay, sexiest man alive,
what has it done for you?
Because you also came
from a choir background
where you were kind of exposed
to a lot of different music probably too.
- I was exposed to a
lot of different music,
but it really is fun doing this.
I think people don't
realize how much fun it is
to coach other artists.
- Yeah.
- I did use to direct
choirs when I was younger
and I was a minister
of music at my church.
But this coaching aspect, I
haven't really done since then
and doing that for, you
know, 12 artists, 10 artists,
whatever we have that season.
It's really fun, it's really exciting.
But it's also a little bit heartbreaking
cause you have to let
people go so quickly.
- Yeah.
- And like we pick 12 people for our team.
We're so excited.
We try to convince all 12 of them to come
and then a week later we're
like, bye to half of them.
And it's really hard
because you already get attached to them.
You're inspired by them.
- You see their potential.
- Yeah, you see their potential
and then you have to let
people go so quickly.
- Yeah, that freaked me out
the first season I did it.
But then the producers kept reminding me,
they know what they're signing up for
and you know what, I'm one of those kids
and you do know what
you're signing up for.
- Yeah.
- That everybody's getting off it.
- Also it's like one of those things
where we're all on a journey,
we're all going home
and it's all just a moment
in our life journey.
And so if you look at it like that,
it's just an amazing thing
that you're going through
in that moment,
you're gonna always have to
move on to something else.
- It's a good lesson to
learn like right off the bat.
- It is true.
- Yes and we all deal
with rejection in our business.
- [Kelly] Never.
- We've dealt with it from
the beginning of our careers
and we've gotten to this place
and we're very fortunate.
But even now we still deal with rejection.
- [Kelly] Amen.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I'm just kidding.
This season has been so fun.
I cannot wait for everybody
to see these blinds.
Cause I feel like since you
are sitting next to Blake,
you two, the banter is so funny.
You give him crap right back.
And not a lot of people hang there.
- I learned that you have
to preempt his crap giving.
- Oh my gosh, you nailed it.
- Just jump him, beat him to it.
- Gosh, it was good.
- It's been a lot of fun.
- It was literally my favorite
blinds we've ever shot.
- Really?
- Yeah, I told the producers, I was like,
it felt like I was
getting paid to have fun.
Like I was like, this is awesome.
I was going home at night and
I was like, I love my jobs.
So your second run on
The Voice starts tonight.
So how are you feeling this time?
You feel like way more
relaxed about giving us crap,
which I love.
- I now view all of you as
like my brothers and sister.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- And so I don't really care.
I'm just gonna --
- No one has feelings.
- Let, let it go.
And just, just take you guys down a notch.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- No, it's been fun.
I honestly love doing
the show with you guys
and working with these incredible artists,
but I learned a lot from
the first season, you know,
and just interacting with them.
We're coaches, sure,
but I think the thing
that's so cool is that
we also learn so much in
the process about ourselves
and the artists we're working with
and how to give each other crap.
And that's been the most
fun and rewarding part
of being on the show for a second season.
- Well, because you have
to navigate the person.
Because all the coaches are different.
You're like, how far can I push this one?
- Well, that was the first
thing on like day one
of my first season.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Nick] I didn't know if I
was going to offend someone.
There's always that line.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- [Nick] But then I realized
you guys are hard to offend.
- It takes an awful lot to offend me.
And usually when people are offensive,
if it's at least funny, I'm like, points.
- [Nick] Okay.
- All right.
- Yeah, there's been a few things.
I can't remember exactly which things,
but times where it was like,
oh that stung a little bit too much.
- Oh man, so my bad,
we'll hug it out when we can after COVID.
- [Nick] Yeah, we'll hug it out.
- Okay.
- - [Nick] Well we can't.
- Yeah, we can't now, but afterwards.
Well there's a history of the guys
being named the sexiest man alive.
We've talked about this in
interviews we've all done.
- It doesn't really make sense.
(Kelly laughing)
I mean, if we have to talk about this,
but Blake Shelton and John Legend,
depending if I ever was
invited into this brotherhood.
- [Kelly] Adam is in it as well.
- Adam.
- [Kelly] He was one of them.
- [Nick] Makes more sense.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Those three, okay.
So I think, you know, I would
question the validity of this.
- [Kelly] You question it.
You think they're running out of people?
- I think they're running out of people.
- Yeah.
- I think that maybe Blake
paid somebody, you know,
I don't wanna start rumors here.
- He did something for it.
Remind us what you know, your teams get,
you know, mine get a jacket.
What does your team get?
- My team gets a customized song.
- Now customized, you mean,
like you just changed the name.
- Yeah, changed the name and
what it rhymes with each,
each rendition.
- Wait, my favorite one was
the one that you didn't.
There was no other word
to rhyme with it, but.
- But the women's body parts, yeah.
And I didn't wanna say it.
I wanted everyone to know
that I was thinking it,
but I didn't say it and
let their mind do the work.
- It was amazing.
What do you do?
Nick's notes, right, the journal?
- I do a journal, which
I think is a great gift.
- [John] Especially if you have pilot pen.
- Especially if you have a G2 pilot pen
that's in my own hand.
- I'll trade you a jacket for that?
- [Kelly] You know what, okay.
Blake what do you give them?
Oh, I forgot.
- Trophies.
- This, no, oh my gosh.
(all laughing)
- I set him up!
Whatever.
- This has been a lot of fun.
I'm enjoying this a lot.
- This year he's not getting
the trophy this year.
I wanna talk about some
of our favorite moments
from The Voice.
So mine is obviously
when I win this season.
John, what is yours?
- I didn't know we were
having kind of conjecture.
- Yeah, it's all about projection.
- As our favorite moment (laughing).
My favorite was when I won
my first season, season 16.
That was pretty cool.
With Maelyn Jarmon.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [John] That was pretty cool.
- Yeah, I loved winning.
Who doesn't love it?
- [John] Winning's awesome.
- What's your favorite?
- Nick doesn't know what that feels like.
- I haven't won.
There's that?
No, my favorite moment.
- [John] Awkward.
- I have a few.
I think back to season 18 when
Blake brought out the puppy.
- [Kelly] Snowflake.
- [John] Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] I wanted him.
- [John] Oh and then you put
it back in the shelter after.
- Yeah, well I was honest.
I said what was gonna happen if
whoever that was that didn't pick me.
- Yeah, and look what happened.
- They left a mark though.
You wanted him pretty badly.
If you don't remember their name.
- The fans didn't like that artist either.
- Yeah.
- Cause they let the puppy
go back to the shelter.
Backfired on him.
Would've won The Voice and saved the dog.
- What's your favorite
moment from this season?
- From this season, so far,
I mean, Victor, who's fantastic.
He was voted through to
the semifinals by the fans
and his first song on the show
during the blind auditions
was my Oscar winning song with Common.
- Yeah.
- Lori and Blake was the
first to turn for Victor.
And his pitch was like, you
must really love gospel music.
And he just kept kinda rambling.
- I associate the word glory with gospel.
- He's just rambling and
trying to bond with him.
And I look at you and I'm like,
he doesn't know it's my song.
- [Kelly] He did literally look at me.
Here's the thing.
- In my defense, I don't think he's
ripping out Boys Around Here.
- Hey, you have no idea
what I'm playing in my car.
- Hey, no, on a group text,
remember, they were at Christy's,
they were listening to you.
- We were listening.
- [Kelly] They were.
- That was true.
- Hey and that's why, just so you know,
they're records, they're
vinyl records today
because of that moment,
I gave them your record on vinyl.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
- Just so he knew your music.
- And Gloria's not on that album.
- It's not on that album, that is correct.
- I looked on the back of it.
- It is on the soundtrack to Selma.
- I was like that's John's only damn song.
(John laughing)
- What's your favorite
moment from this season?
- I've had a couple favorite moments.
I've had a couple favorite performances.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- Actually I think Victor
Solomon's performance
and Dana Monique's from this last week.
- Oh Yeah, Dana was amazing.
- That was Free Your Mind, right?
- [John] Free Your Mind.
Yeah, that was incredible.
- You know, also Dana
Monique, her journey,
her story of kind of coming
from being a background singer,
always being in the background
to having a moment to step out
and really shine on her own
and having belief from me and John.
And unfortunately for John,
picking me as her coach,
- Unfortunately.
- Meant a lot.
But she said, you know.
- It was amazing.
I said I have a lot to prove.
I feel like you do too.
And that became our sort of connection.
That was a special moment.
- The best block ever used in any season
was this season against him for Kenzie.
- Mr. Mullet himself.
- He literally looks like
he could be your nephew.
(John laughing)
- [Blake] Poor kid, you just crushed him.
- [John] He was like, he
was made to be on your team.
- [Kelly] You just wait until
you see his song I gave him.
- You crushed his chances.
- [Kelly] Whatever.
- He was made to be on your team.
And she blocked you.
- I do, I apologize
every time I see him, no kidding.
I go, I'm really sorry.
I was like, I mean, I'm
kind of so glad I did it,
but I'm really sorry.
Anyway.
We're okay cowboy.
What's your favorite
moment from this season?
- I like when I turned
around and it was Pete Morrow
standing back there that I hadn't seen.
For all I knew the guy was in
prison or dead or something.
Like I hadn't seen him in
that like 25 years, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I didn't even recognize him.
I mean like.
- No we're aware.
- [Blake] Huh?
- We're aware that you
didn't recognize your friend.
- I was like, that's not Pete.
The Pete had, when I knew
him, he wore like the mobetta.
He had like a Garth hat.
And then, now he's Pete, like that Pete.
I didn't recognize him, get over it.
- Oh my God, that was
actually my favorite.
- It's going to happen
to you one of these days.
And I can't wait.
- My favorite moment was turning around
and realizing he was
supposed to know Pete.
I was, I mean, I get it.
You don't see each other for a long time,
but it was pretty funny.
- I really liked Pete
and I was trying to get him
to join my team outta spite.
You know.
- He wasn't doing it.
- No, no, no, no.
And there's something, it's
the gravitational pull.
It's annoying, I know.
What has been the best
thing about coaching so far?
- Other than just getting to know you all
and spend that time and laugh so hard.
I just love seeing the
talent that's on the show
and getting to know these
artists and work with them.
It's just like a really special experience
to be able to share some
of what we've learned
and been able to do in our
lives with these artists
that are just wanting
to do the same thing.
It's this really special opportunity
to be able to share that with people,
to be in that position
is really interesting.
It's just so cool to be there.
And yeah, they're all so
nice and cool, I love them.
I'm obsessed with my team.
I talk to them all the time.
- You come home with your first team too.
It's like, you get so obsessed.
You love them all.
But like your first, it's so exciting.
- I've broken every role in my contract.
I've talked to them all, all the time.
I'm like DMing them.
They're like, you're
not supposed to do that.
And I'm like, sorry.
(Kelly laughing)
- No, I know you're sending
stuff to the hotel for them.
You're very, this is the
coolest thing about you though.
I really hope people get to see from you.
Like just working with you on the show.
Like backstage, I have to
have my eye makeup redone,
like she's hysterical.
She's so funny, very quick witted.
I didn't know this about you.
I knew you were a talented,
I knew you'd be a great coach.
I knew all those things,
but I didn't know how funny you were
because we'd never really hung much.
- It' lifeless, I know.
It seems totally made up.
- We only see when we're watching it,
we only see like performing.
- For sure and like Seven
Rings, which is like, what?
Who is that, you know?
- Well, that's a great song.
- Thank you.
But like, what does that mean?
- That's like one of my favorites.
- You know what I mean,
that's not a person.
- It's not a person, she's a robot.
- Punchline, you know what I mean.
- No, but you're hilarious.
And I thought it was so interesting
because usually it takes
coaches that come on,
like just being there for eight seasons,
it takes them a minute to like,
get used to being free with their words
and like their personality.
And you kind of like, right,
it was like, I think the second
or third day of the blinds,
you were like, nevermind, I'm here.
And it was like, awesome.
Did you find it nerve-wracking?
- It was a little nerve-wracking
but you all made me feel so comfortable
and are the nicest people
that I've met in this whole thing.
Like just the most fun ever.
And you made me feel so comfortable.
So it's because of you guys,
you guys were push
and also Blake was
pushing all the buttons.
Sorry, I'll shut up.
- But you know what though,
he does though because he feels able to.
That's when I feel like
it's the best chemistry.
- That's helpful.
- Yeah, it's helpful.
It sets you up up for jokes.
- It does, he gives you
a good setup every time.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he just opens his mouth.
- Yes.
That's it.
- Well, they act tough.
- [Ariana] He just walks in.
- He just walks in and
there's a joke coming,
but Blake and John are,
they are terrified of you, look at this.
- [Ariana] Oh?
- Yes.
- Ariana has a huge fan base
and they are fervent.
And if they show up to
vote, we're all in trouble.
- 100%, are you scared at all?
- Now, what?
I'm not afraid of her fan
base, where are they at?
Look at me, where's the camera.
Bring it on Ariana fans, bring it on.
I'm not afraid of Ariana.
- He is so afraid of Ariana's fan base.
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
Thoughts?
We said this when you came in,
I mean, it was apparent.
Literally the entire
audience was screaming
and we were like, we have no chance.
Like it was like, it was amazing.
- I don't know that that's true.
- Well, I'm just saying like you have--
- I do not think that that's true.
- But you're like a, you're a huge star.
I don't know.
- What are you talking
about, Kelly Clarkson!
- No, I'm just saying,
it's one of those things
that you watch out.
(audience clapping)
No, it's so different.
- Sorry.
- Anyway, we're all,
it's gotta feel a little good.
The little bit of competitiveness in you
has gotta be like, they're
all a little terrified.
- I really don't think
that I have the chance
you think I have.
- You can think all you
want, but it's true.
- First of all.
Thank you.
The beautiful thing about it is that
even just being on the show,
this is such a beautiful
chance for them to be seen
by the world in a new way.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is just us getting to meet them
and give them this first chance.
And it's really special.
Cause I think you're gonna
fall in love with all of them.
I really do.
- They're so good.
(audience clapping)
- One of my favorite moments
of the whole season so far was
the coach performance.
Because like just getting
to sing with this woman
and also Blake and John,
it was just such an incredible experience.
Like the coolest part was
the rehearsal beforehand
where all of us were just
sitting around a piano
and just like hearing
their voices in the room
was so special.
Cause you're so familiar with their voices
because of their huge records.
And you hear them all the time.
- No, it was fun.
It was my favorite part.
- [Ariana] It was so special.
- Yeah.
- [Ariana] What a cool memory.
I was like, I gotta sing now.
That's not fair, bye.
- Shut up, oh my God.
- Okay.